hi everyone welcome to homeroom with sal
we have a very exciting conversation and
i also have two temporary co-hosts today
because our guest is a bit of a a hero
for them we have a bit of a chess
household uh so we're going to have a a
hopefully a very uh engaging
conversation with magnus carlson world
chess champion highest rated chess
player about all things chess and life
and getting better at things that might
seem hard at first but before we jump
into that conversation i will give my
standard announcements first of all
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit we can only exist through
philanthropic donations so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
going to khanacademy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to a whole series of
organizations that really helped step up
when it was clear that the world was
depending on khan academy more than ever
during the pandemic and we were running
at a deficit so special thanks to bank
of america att google.org novartis
fastly and general motors and our many
other supporters of all levels hundreds
of thousands of folks
who donate whatever they can to make
khan academy a possibility
i also want to remind everyone that
there is a podcast version of this live
stream wherever you get your podcast
homeroom with sal
the podcast so with that i'm excited to
introduce magnus world chess champion
magnus great to have you here
thank you thank you so much great to be
here
and and this is a very special occasion
we've never had uh quite this many
uh uh co-hosts on on this on the session
it's because of you you know maybe we're
getting so many questions that are
coming in over social media and beyond
maybe a good place to start is
you know where when you were young when
did you first realize that you had for
lack of a better word a gift that chess
was something that you were drawn to and
that you might be able to stand out in
i think it sort of started when i was uh
nine and a half years old
uh i i started playing chess a little
bit later than
uh than many of the other kids but i
could notice that i was uh
i was uh
sponging up information in a way that
they were not so like i i would play
tournaments with kids my age pretty much
every weekend and i could feel that i
was sort of improving week by
week by week and uh and and they were
not and i realized that i had just
uh
much more of a passion and a drive to do
this than than they had so i think
that's that's when i realized that i
could actually be very good at this
and and we have questions coming in from
instagram
creation
uh asks who taught you how to play chess
how did you get introduced to the game
and you mentioned it was relatively late
for someone who gets to your level of
chess
oh yeah absolutely so um my father is
quite a keen chess player um
he still enjoys playing
playing playing chess a lot i would say
he plays
probably more chess than i do to be to
be honest
um
uh he taught
uh taught me and my sister at a fairly
young age uh
but
up till the age i was i was eight uh i
really didn't didn't know much at all uh
but certainly without him i would never
have
um pursued chess the way that i i did
and and we having tons of questions you
could imagine from
both experienced and beginner chess
players from instagram clara is asking
and i'm curious whether you followed
your own advice but what is the most
important thing beginners should work on
to get better at chess and what were you
working on when you were a beginner
the thing is i
don't think i was working on anything in
particular
um
so
we had some
uh
some chess books and magazines
at home so i would read them
um
and there was this own there was this
uh
chest chessboard we had so i would move
the pieces around sometimes trying to
imitate the games that i'd seen
seen there but like after learning the
very
uh basics and the rules from from my
father it was more really a case of me
just trying out
um different things and seeing what
worked
was it really you know just when as you
started playing other people it was a
bit of a rocket ship you just realized
hey there's things you're processing
that other people aren't you're getting
better faster were there times that you
were starting to plateau and you had to
do certain things to get out of that to
get to another level uh there were
certainly
uh
there were certainly times when i was
younger when yeah i couldn't
reach um
reach that next level immediately and in
hindsight uh
obviously that's
that's something that happens to
everybody um what i believed back then
is i had this sort of irrational
confidence that
these are so these are temporary
setbacks like the only reason why i'm
not progressing to the next level is
because
i've had some bad lurk or
in this particular tournament i wasn't
able to to show my best so i always
believe that i'm gonna pull through like
next tournament next game that that's
gonna be that's gonna be mine uh
and i think that
mentality more than anything else is
what
um
allowed me uh allowed me to to push to
push through
yeah and you know i'm asking you all of
these questions because uh people might
not realize i'm going to play a
computerized 10 year old version of you
uh in a in a few days so i'm trying to
get as many tips as possible to improve
my chess game and and you probably uh
here's the little card about uh we're
gonna i'm gonna be playing your
computerized ten-year-old magnus and i
i'm a reasonably serious amateur but i'm
i'm i i don't wanna raise anyone's
expectations uh too much and and magnus
you probably don't remember this but
about i would like to say about four or
five years ago we actually played each
other at an event uh this was at out
here in silicon valley where i was
randomly selected from a hat i was one
of four people to play you you're
blindfolded i know you probably do this
a lot but it was very memorable for me
it was
i and and i was the last person standing
uh so that was a um
an exciting blindfolded timed time or
yes that was one
time
yeah then i i then i remember yeah
i'm sure that game you remember vividly
in your head as you know
[Laughter]
uh no but is that a game where i forgot
the position once
yes you do remember the game yeah i
briefly i briefly had an advantage i i
tell people i don't believe
i think i blended a rook or something
because i re i
i misremembered one of the puns as as
far as i can i was up a look at one
point in the game
and and i tell this to everyone who
would listen i was at one point at an
advantage versus magnus carlson and then
i later tell him that you were
blindfolded playing four other people
and i think you even had might have had
less time on your clock than i did
but it was good for my self-esteem
i remember the moment when i saw that
i'm like
he's he's doing something really deep
something really deep because i think i
can just take this
no i i
surprisingly often when you see a very
strong player
appear to to miss something obvious they
just missed it
so
uh that's what i i keep telling telling
everybody if it looks like your opponent
missed something
and you can't see why they didn't they
probably did
that's actually good life advice because
i think all the time we question when
when there's something good good
happening you know i think this relates
actually my two of my kids uh who are
very such serious chess players is imran
and this is azad who've been hanging out
here why don't you all ask your
questions they're actually missing
schoolwork for this i'm not i think
schoolwork well okay
ask your question as either nimrod you
ask your question and i'll i'll i'll
follow up what's your question assad how
do you beat all the people
how do you beat all the people okay
we're gonna we're gonna put that in the
oh well do you have a response to that
how do you beat all the people
um
i don't know to be honest uh and i i
don't beat all of them uh
more talent harder work who knows
talent and hard work you hear that is
that yes okay and then ron what's your
question
so like when you play blindfolded like
you get it get against my dad like is
there any specific like way that you can
memorize the entire multiple boards in
your head or do you just
do it
i think you sort of store them in
different parts of your brain so it's
really
uh it's really only necessary to have
um one board at a time
but it's good to uh um
it's good to have some
some kind of face or some kind of name
that you connect with with it with a
certain board so it's easier to
distinguish them from each other
yeah i mean and it's following on
actually on both of their questions
famously and i think a lot of people and
you've commented on queen's gambit a lot
of people are really getting into chess
these days but it does seem like people
who can perform even close to your level
seem to have almost superhuman memories
and it seems like you do remember a lot
of you the fact that you remember that
game versus me which is you know
probably the least important game you've
ever played um does speak to that
is this something you've trained is it
only in chess or do you have ability to
memorize scenarios and visualize things
outside of chess as well
i would say that when i was young i had
a very very good memory uh
now it's
no it's not so
so great anymore uh i would say at this
point my memory is it's nothing
exceptional like i can remember
i can remember patterns
still i can remember the broad ideas
uh
but i cannot remember everything like i
mean let me tell you that when i was
young when i was a
um
when i was a when i was a teenager at
least in my early teens like
there is no way
uh that i would be able to
to only tell you that i blended rook at
some point because i displaced my
this place my pawn uh back then i would
have been able to tell you the whole
game and
and details uh about it um so i think uh
i think now it's it's more
as you get older it's it's more it's
more about
uh it's more about
remembering the the broad lines of
everything and i i don't don't think i'm
pretty uh really exceptional there
and and i think you're probably being
being humble but it is fascinating that
you're saying that in some ways you're
how your brain tackles chess and you've
stayed at the top of your game this
entire time but it has transitioned from
being more i guess you could say memory
intensive or computational intensive and
now it's more almost pattern recognition
uh is what i'm hearing and there's
there's a question from instagram brian
it's related to this does being a world
champion stop you from constantly trying
to improve your chess you know how do
you know how do you get better when when
when you're frankly you're you're the
best right now how how do you push
yourself to be better
frankly uh
the emphasis for me is on learning
and
i don't know exactly how that is going
to make me a better chess player
but i feel
as though
my understanding of chess is is evolving
looking at my games
let's say five six years ago
i would say
that
my understanding of the game was
considerably
considerably worse back then
my results weren't necessarily worse
um
but that is the fascinating part for me
is
is that
it's it's the game is the game is
evolving my understanding it's
is evolving um
and
always learn learning something new um
and
that really is enough motivation for me
uh to
to keep on keep on learning whether
it will make me a better chess player um
i don't know uh because
sometimes in chess ignorance really can
be
can be bliss because
um if you have sometimes if you have
less knowledge
but
knowledge that you are confident about
it's can be better than just
having uh many many
many many ideas many many
uh thoughts that
you
uh that you
just makes you overthink
that's fascinating i mean i'm really
actually blown away by that the comment
where you say that four or five years
ago your understanding of the game was
much less deep than it is today because
four or five years ago you were already
world chess champion and you're saying
that you had a you had a a more
superficial understanding of the game so
i mean it's fascinating that there's
still layers that you are uncovering
even after becoming world chess champion
yeah
absolutely uh and i think that happens
to
um to all chess players because the game
is evolving and it's
it's the tragedy
strategy for for everybody that
um
the more you know um
the the worse you play
becomes at some point
and i'm curious you know as someone who
is a a an amateur chess player but i'm
sure even many experienced chess players
what goes on in your head
you know in a lot of chess someone like
me
i might recognize certain things but i'm
also doing a lot of the scenarios well
if i do this they're going to do this if
i do this they're going to do this and i
can go down that tree maybe three or
four or five moves at best
are you doing that same type of thing
wait if i do this they do that or is it
is it something else
oh it can be uh
but
i think i
since i'm much more experienced i would
use sort of my long-term
memory uh more than my short-term
but
clearly sometimes you do have to
to calculate and
then it's uh as you say no
no deeper than yeah if i do this you
will have to do this
and then then i'll do do that and so on
and then there may be
um
two or three options on on each move so
the the three of variation sort of
becomes
um broader and and messier but um
at the end of the day you can't
escape sort of calculation by by by
brute force uh no matter
no matter how
how much you you want to play on
intuition and uh strategy rather than
tactics
i can imagine and we have a question
here from facebook margot mcginnis who's
actually helped coordinates
the first time we played and now this
time that i'm going to be playing versus
the digital you
but what was your most this is margo's
question what was your most memorable or
nerve-wracking match and i'll add to
this do you get how do you deal with
stress do you get nervous during matches
uh yeah i would certainly say
the uh the first world championship
match
um
at this
that i had in 2013 at the start i was so
so nervous that i dropped one of my
pieces on the on the first move
uh and
uh
which is
sort of fascinating um
because even at that point i was the
highest rated player in the world that
was very experienced but
the task of playing a world championship
was so daunting to me that uh
um
that for the first four games or yeah
three or four games i was still
um unbelievably nervous because it was
something that was absolutely new to me
and how do you deal with that you just
say you know breathe
one move at a time kind of thing
i don't know how to deal with it to be
honest so the day the way that i dealt
with it was
uh
i played one good game and then
my confidence was back and
i didn't have a care in the world
and
like
very often
people search for
um like
do i have any method or
deeper meaning to what i do
but
what i explained at the beginning was
my method was mainly trial and error and
it still is the summit to some extent
that
i find out what
works for me at some point simply by
um by by experiencing it not not
necessarily by by good planning
and you ever while you're in the middle
of a game i mean less experience we
always oh i can't believe i made that
move like that was a but how often does
that happen to you that you're like oh
my god that was a careless mistake or i
can't believe i did that
every single game
ah
yeah i can't remember a single one where
uh where i haven't
um where i haven't had those those
thoughts like sometimes it would be a
massive blender another
um
another time it will be an unavoidable
uh inaccuracy
uh but every time it's like
you've played chess your whole life and
still you can't figure this out
it's uh yeah it's it's the same
and it sounds like you know to your
earlier comment about that that moment
which i i will never stop bragging about
where i had an advantage versus you
playing blindfolded against four other
people um is
is is what you said earlier i mean you
probably hide it well because now
when you make what you know is to be a
mistake or you miss something most other
people will probably see it as
a deep insight
it's something that
it probably scares them
yeah normally it's just uh it's just a
mess
up
that's what it is
you know there's a lot of questions
coming in about uh you know chess and
your life uh you know i guess this is a
question youtube ghost tommy how's chess
affected your life
how have you
has it improved you uh
and i'll extend that question of how are
you viewing chess and your life going
forward and you've achieved the top of
your game literally at a very very young
age you're still very very young what do
you see is the future do you feel you
know defending your title do you is this
right you're constantly on your game or
is it really just the love of the game
and and what else is going on outside of
chess
uh no really i i just want to
want to learn
and
playing both
tournaments and casual games
still give me still give me
satisfaction and joy so
for the moment i haven't really thought
too much about
anything else
[Music]
whatever titles
may be out there that's
uh that's not the main motivation at
this point um
in that case i feel like it's just
come with me it's it's about
it's about learning and and having fun
to be honest
yeah i know it's good to hear that i
mean
it's amazing when you even said that how
much more you've learned about the game
of chess
over the last four or five years when
you're already at the top of the game it
really does sound like there's this
opportunity this journey there's a
beauty in the game that never never gets
old and related to that there's a
question here from facebook cynthia
hurtado and this is this is a good
question something i've always wondered
what do you think about the rise of
chess engines and and the digital age of
chess how has that changed the game how
does it change your thinking
is it different to play against a super
computer versus a great human player
uh frankly i don't play
play a lot against computers uh like
basically only time that i play against
computer opponents is when i play my own
app
and
computers have
changed dramatically
the way that we
prepare for um for games
not necessarily for
for the better because it's
left sort of less scope for
um for creativity
um i think
computers though have made the game much
more accessible for for casual fans
because
now you can sort of see uh you can see a
score and and they can also aid in
giving you instant feedback when you
play your your your games so i i guess
overall um
they they've certainly been a positive
but
in terms of
how i view
chess engines i view them as
as
more of a um
for me a necessary evil than
than than a good good thing um
to me it would be
um
yeah the game would be just as
interesting without uh computer analysis
and and
you know you said a really interesting
thing that i've heard great chess
players say you know the creativity of
the game the beauty of the game and i
definitely have glimpses of that when i
sometimes play but
double click on that a little bit what
do you mean where it says you know when
you play against human versus human
there's maybe a little more space for
creativity
what does that mean
it just means that
humans have
they have uh they have emotions
they have
actual thoughts
so
you can
it's sort of a game of
of
both some emotion and and ideas and with
computers it just becomes
um technique
basically it's so it's only about
technique and uh that's why i find it in
general less interesting
is that part of your game and i find it
fascinating you know chess famously was
built off of a metaphor for real warfare
in the real world ancient warfare and
ancient warfare we all know isn't just
who is the best tactical fighter it is
there's psychology there's tricks
there's uh there's faints
how much do you
how much of that is a game at a at the
very highest level where you know i do
imagine these people who are playing
with each other can you know they're
thinking way down the road they can
think about the positions they can think
about all these things how much of is it
playing with the other person's emotions
or tricking them or making them not see
something kind of do a faint of hand
things like that
i think there's more
uh
the faster the games the more there's
room for
all sorts of uh of uh trickery uh that
to
my mind makes makes the game more more
interesting uh
i i think
when you have
more again as you have more and more
time it becomes
becomes more
more technical um but
certainly
at shorter time controls there's there's
a lot of a lot of psychology involved
and it then it's
there's much more room to
um
to sort of adjust your strategy
according to
to your your opponents
yeah and and you know when you when you
uh
i think a lot of people have watched
queen's gambit i've seen on social media
you've commented on queen's gambit a
good bit
i mean i am curious in this forum you
know what are your thoughts about it and
and do you think it was pretty realistic
to the game of chess and you know the
main character in queen's gambit she's
famously is kind of an intuitive player
uh versus a a kind of a computational
i'm sure she's doing some of that too or
at least that the character would what
are your thoughts about it and what's it
done to the game of chess
uh well i think the only reason she can
be intuitive is that she studied very
very hard
and that's
uh what i one of the things i love to
see uh
about the series is that she
uh she studies so
so hard and she has such great respect
for
for the game uh
also i feel like they
did the chess
uh pretty pretty well there um the
fragments from
from games were very uh realistic
and um
and and sometimes beautiful as well
uh
uh when it comes to to the atmosphere
around the tournaments and so on i guess
some things are are fictionalized but
overall i
i was very very happy with it and
um hopefully um
people will watch it and they will not
be
uh be scared but rather encouraged to
um to to play chess
yeah and you know there's so many
questions i know we're running a long
time but i'll ask a few more of these
really around how do you cope with
especially in the early days when maybe
you were getting beaten every now and
then how did you deal with that failure
uh and and how do you how do you manage
your own emotions i mean are there times
that you get where you you're feeling
either bad about yourself or angry uh or
or frustrated with a given opponent
i have to say that
when i was young and i guess i lost a
lot more than i did i do now
i didn't
i didn't care so much about losses
because i i didn't expect to win all the
time uh as i said it was
like i wanted to play stronger players
that i i could learn the most and it was
not about
it was not about winning i i just
wanted to
to sort of
get to to the next
next level like
um
that i could match up with stronger and
stronger
uh opponents and then beat them
eventually
um in recent years when i've become used
to
being at the top most of the time
um yeah now losing
losing hurts uh
i i'm not gonna lie there like every
every time and it's not it's not even
losing like i might be
equally upset after a game that i won as
a game that i lost if i feel like i did
something
i made a mistake that i could easily
easily have avoided or i didn't act
professionally uh enough in
in the way that i i executed the game um
so
uh yeah um
20 years of playing playing chess has
not prevented me from having
sort of um emotional reactions to to
things that happen uh at chessboard
and how do you deal you know one of the
things that i think is hard when people
have been so successful for so long
do you sometimes model in your mind what
if
five years ten years in the future the
next magnus carlson comes and is able to
beat me is that something that you think
about is that how would you how do you
think you that would that would affect
you if that happened
i remember i was asked this question
uh
i think 11 years ago
and at that point it upset me because
they worded the question
as
what what are you gonna do
when
that next one comes along
and
i
i said very clearly that in my mind this
was the question of if
uh
and
also that i thought i have so many years
till that will be
[Music]
be a real thing
um
i think i'm realistic enough uh though
at this point to realize that
i'm not gonna be able to be at the
highest level for forever so if i do
want to um
if i do want to keep
keep on playing chess at the highest
level then at some point i'm going to
um to start
to start regressing but um
for the moment
um i'm thinking like i should still
should still be in in
in my prime and that's what i should
strive towards
yeah no i definitely phrase it as if i'm
not assuming that anyone is gonna
obviously the the most likely scenario
is that somebody's gonna surpass me
um
i wouldn't say sooner rather than later
but uh in the not too distant future
but i'm gonna i'm gonna try and and hold
on as long as i can
and what what what do you know when we
think about the arc of the game of chess
how it's evolved do you think that the
competition is only going higher and
higher and higher over time that people
are understanding the game at deeper and
deeper levels or do you think some of
the old greats from 50 years ago or 60
years ago or even 100 years ago would
actually still be great today
i think it's a bit of both um
the game is certainly certainly evolving
especially with
uh with the computers has made us
reevaluate
a lot of the
the the throat the truth that we we um
held to be self-evident once upon a time
but i also do feel
and this is gonna
make me sound a lot older than i am
but it
i do feel that some of the youngsters
today
uh
they're not too good at the basics like
i feel like the
generation
that i'm a part of and the generation
um before
maybe
understood the fundamentals of the game
a little bit better than
uh than the kids do today and i think
that's
partly
a result of uh
um
growing up with uh
with the
with the
um computer rather than
rather than a board
hmm no it's fascinating because i'm sure
the youngsters that you're talking about
are
are still quite good at chess but you're
saying even some obviously yes
even some of these folks when you say
the basics what do you mean by that like
what types of things do you think they
have maybe some gaps in
i think some gaps in
just
general positional understanding of the
game
um and
that
studying like studying the classic games
i think has has clear clear value like
far from everything that you learn
from from
from back then is
still true today but i don't think
you can develop a broad enough
understanding of uh of the game to be
the best uh by only
by only training with uh with the
computer
no it's it's fascinating and yes you do
sound older than you are yeah
yeah i i just turned
30 last last november um
what i will say though i think i'm lucky
to be in sort of a hybrid generation
there that i was i sort of started
playing
chess before
uh
before the computers were were
absolutely everywhere
uh like i actually went to
to a school with
books and
notebooks and so on uh before everything
became computerized and so on and
i think it's it's sort of a good
position to be in to be in that sort of
a hybrid that you can you have a good
knowledge of
of of computers but that you can also uh
you can also sort of
relate to
um
to the old way the game was was played
yeah and maybe in the time we have left
you know one one question that i'm sure
a lot of people and people are asking
this question you know what other
subjects are you interested in math or
physics there's sometimes connection
between chess but i am curious have you
ever done the the thought exercise if if
you weren't world chess champion or if
you didn't have this chess life in that
alternate reality what would magnus
carlsen be doing
yeah i've been asked it many times for
sure
never had a good answer uh probably
still
don't
one thing that i will say though is that
i have
massive respect
for
people
in
almost any any field and
i think there are a lot even fairly
bright people who think
that
somebody like me
could become good at something else with
very little effort
uh
but i i don't really don't don't think
so i think
most of all i'm somebody who
evidently i have some talent for
for chess but most of all i've spent a
lot of time working on it and thinking
uh about it and i think
that i'm not necessarily
the fastest
at at anything uh
i i need some time i
and then then i i just keep
keep learning
but
to think of something else
uh
no i don't think
like there's anything that i could just
um that i could imagine i would be
anywhere um
equally as as good at in that case i
would have to
to spend nearly all my time on it as i
have with chess
yeah i mean well it does seem like the
mindset that you've taken to chess and i
i there are there's probably things your
mind can do that would be very useful in
other fields even even if we limit
ourselves to game do you play other
games or have you ever you know famously
a lot of elite athletes who you know
michael jordan tried golf lebron james i
recently read an article of like he
could have been a football player have
you thought well there's other games i
could have played you know go or mahjong
or just something else
have you ever tried have you ever tried
these things or or do you even play
other games outside of chess
the thing is for something like go i
feel like
chess might almost be
uh having spent a lot of time on chess
might almost be a
disadvantage
uh
because i think that the mindset there
is is very
different and for a chess player goal
seems very very
very abstract compared to
compared to chess
i wouldn't say i'm great at anything
else
i mean i've tried games like i play
play poker with my friends uh
occasionally without being particularly
great at it i've tried
um
yeah i tried shogi go briefly without
excelling at any any of those uh things
so i really i really wouldn't know
yeah
you know i just imagine playing poker or
any other game against you and i do
think you you have an intimidation
factor which would play to your strength
it goes away it goes away very quickly
[Laughter]
well well i know we're all out of time i
mean first of all thank you so much i
look forward to playing the robot
version of you which i still will i'm
pretty sure will crush me uh but i'm
going to practice with my uh
co-conspirators that you met earlier my
older is it you know he's he's he's
pretty decent he's i think just gotten
better than me
so
he gives me my run for the money but
magnus thank you so much
yeah you know thank you so much
obviously
fascinating what you've been able to
accomplish in chess but i think even
more
chess as a metaphor for life is very
powerful and what you've been able to do
in the game and just understanding a
little bit of how you think about chess
and life i think has a lot of insights
that go well beyond chess
so so thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you so much for for having me and
uh
all the best to to to all of you in this
difficult time
great thank you so much magnus
so thanks everyone for joining uh
today's homeroom uh as uh
all uh you know i i could have talked to
magnus for a few more hours i i i feel
like we got glimpses into what goes on
in his mind uh both intellectually and
emotionally uh and you know some of the
takeaways he's a human being just like
the rest of us but it would be it would
be fun to to be able to see a chess
board the way that he sees a chess board
but you can see
a 10 year old robot version of magnus
crushing me likely in chess it's all
about setting expectations in the right
place um
we're going to have a a live event uh
and a as a card had shown in a couple of
days
but uh thank you all for for joining us
it's gonna be a champions chess tour dot
com
uh and i'm definitely part of the uh the
entertainment more than the serious
competition oh i do play a little bit as
magnus said it's now documented he not
only not only he remembers the game
which i find incredibly flattering uh
but uh he he also admitted that i
briefly had a moment when he he forgot
something because he was playing for
other people simultaneously without with
a blindfold on but with that thanks so
much for coming to this today's homeroom
and i will see you all next week i think
see you then
you